[Music]
what's going on guys this movie's great
according to john john take it away guys
regardless of our opinions right now if
you're gonna see this movie and you're
gonna decide how you feel you need to
come and see it in an actual theater to
have it wash over you to really
know your thoughts and clearly our
thoughts are a bit divided but before we
get into this just big thanks to
cinemark for having us out you know us
we're always here and there's a good
reason why because it was lovely to
experience this on the big screen as it
was meant to be seen there was even a
commercial before the movie illustrating
that fact and i was like yeah you know i
don't like seeing this on this tiny
little box so uh thanks to cinemark yes
the matrix resurrections is the fourth
film in the matrix franchise and
everybody agrees it's great yeah this is
a very meta outing it's definitely a
different sort of beast from the
original three if you're coming in for
something that looks like it grew
directly out of those movies there's
going to be a lot for you to chew and
swallow and perhaps not be so on board
with different equals good john don't
downplay it no i don't think different
equals it does different equals good but
yeah i don't know for my viewing of this
movie i mean greg you know you are the
self-professed matrix is your favorite
movie of all time i love the matrix as
well obviously your fandom eclipses mine
in terms of your knowledge and your uh
you know vocality on it but for my own
viewing purposes i dug this movie a good
amount i mean i want to see it again and
from coming into the theater i thought
to myself i'll probably have to watch
this a couple times because every matrix
movie is dense but just on first viewing
i had a good time and i enjoyed the take
they went with it's one of those
situations where i can very much
understand a lot of the gripes i have
heard up to this point before the
screening and a lot of the gripes i've
heard after but for me i got invested in
just the return of thomas anderson and
his story where he is now i enjoyed
being in the new you know this version
of the matrix matrix 7.0 or 8.0
whichever version we're in now as far as
a return
i appreciated that it seemed a kin and
built on the original movies but like it
really had its own flavor to run with it
is dealing with a lot of the same ideas
of choice and destiny and identity and
whatnot from the original movies that
stuff at least on this first viewing is
not so new i liked some of the meta
commentary they did and the love story
at the center of it i liked the new cast
of characters as a viewing experience
for me uh it was definitely engaging and
enjoyable and uh the thing i think will
agree on the most is that while i found
some of the action engaging it's not
anywhere near as well shot or assembled
as in the previous films and uh that
might be a make it or break it for some
folks but gregory what did you think
hold on
what's up guys hey hey how are you doing
no dude what's your name
eduardo it's a pleasure to meet you all
right guys you know i am a massive
massive fan of the matrix if you're
watching this channel matrix is my
all-time favorite movie matrix reloading
revolutions i would die on that hill as
a defender of those and i get obsessed
the lore the mythology the complete
package every single different theme
those films dive into almost every year
i find something new to discover about
the trilogy alone i am a major matrix
enthusiast i intentionally did not
re-watch any of them this year because i
knew this was coming out and i didn't
want to have that like fresh feel but
i've seen them enough times to kind of
know and if you watch the trailer
reactions for this you know damn well
that i love to break down everything
that this movie is possibly going to be
doing like i was obsessed with it when
it was all said and done here's my
play-by-play experience first 10 minutes
i'm a little worried right now this is
feeling like terminator genesis they
would recreate scenes from the first
matrix but it felt like the rushed
watered-down version at times that i
would liken it to when you go to like
universal studios and watch actors do
water world like no disrespect to them
that's great for theme park doesn't
translate as well here
on the big screen about 20 to 30 minutes
was this is pretty cynical but uh it's
kind of entertaining it's definitely
amusing pace is a little off a little
cheesy but it's it's amusing still
cynical and then it just kept going
pretty fast and then uh it slowed down
significantly i found this out
afterwards we went with a group of like
eight people to when we watched us at
this event screening and uh apparently
most of us dozed off for a little while
like all of us did except for john and
then by the time i got to the finale i
was like okay there's some there's some
cool stuff in this finale i suppose some
cool shots here there
and uh i don't like this movie and i
don't care about any of this uh that
happened and uh i i don't appreciate
the vision of what this film was i did
make a decision halfway through this
movie when i saw myself ready to fall
asleep i will re-watch this film because
i'm going to try to get understand what
the deeper meaning is if there is any i
really got the vibe that lana wachowski
did not want to make this movie felt
like she was talking at me and not
talking through the characters it was a
film that was like very had this sort of
cynical approach towards ip it was more
meta than i expected i was kind of
feeling like it would be a meta film and
it was exceptionally more meta than i
anticipated it would be it tries to
become like an actual matrix movie but
i'm already left with this feeling of
well i feel like you really don't want
to make this movie because you just
spent like the first 30 minutes telling
me how this is a terrible idea to be
doing this movie and then all the themes
that it explores i don't feel like it
explored anything new it explored a new
topic with ip but it didn't the
thematically i'm like the other matrix
films already did that over the course
of a trilogy you're jam-packing it into
this this this like what i felt like was
a mess of a film jessica henwick the
only newcomer i enjoyed yaya abdulmatine
seemed like okay he's got a little bit
of an interesting new morpheus take and
then i thought it became nothing also i
had a pretty hard time buying neil
patrick harris keanu reeves is enjoyable
carry on moss brings her a game if
there's one thing i'll say if there's
one thing i'll say is a good credit to
this film i actually weirdly as much as
i love the matrix trilogy i've always
thought the chemistry with keanu reeves
and carrie anne moss was a bit off i
don't know about off but i just wasn't
that into it i actually thought they had
really great chemistry here and i could
feel the the fact of like they're
supposed to feel like they have a
history with each other but they don't
understand it take that with the fact
that these guys have known each other
for decades you could feel that in their
performance that resonates but as much
as i wasn't enjoying the the story
itself because a lot of it was due to
filmmaking i like i don't like the
script i'm hating the the editing of
this movie i think it's paced terribly
the one thing i was thinking was all
right if you're getting all that wrong
at least have cool action while there's
like some cool shots to be had that are
cool to look up at at the big screen all
of us except for john perry but no
you're kind of there's one thing you're
kind of wanting to say
the action is nowhere near as smooth or
or inventive or awe inspiring as the
original three i thought the action for
the most part was pretty crappy like i
think there's like shots that are cool
but come on man you guys have seen the
matrix films the hand-to-hand action i
couldn't even tell what the hell was
going on in this movie like the hand was
terrible i have a pretty big keen eye
when it comes to action i'm not even
like hyper critical of it but it really
surprised me it surprised the hell out
of me how i thought the style of the
capturing of the action was
so
for the most part generic i thought in
like there's some scenes that you see in
the trailer of like some bike action
sequences like there are certain really
cool visual shots that they would do but
in terms of action sequences like as
totality especially when it came to
hand-to-hand i couldn't believe how
messy it was how i couldn't tell there
was so choppy so edited and there was
nothing memorable or cool about the
choreography there like the choreography
was so lackluster it kind of felt like
the major trilogy was daredevil
choreography and then matrix
resurrections was iron fist season one i
mean i'm glad you feel this way i'm glad
i wish i had the feelings you had dog
was like like the odd man out in our
group and i was still there feeling like
i wish i had these feelings especially
when i go on social media and i feel
like it seems like most people are
actually really liking it and for me as
someone who is a defender of the ones
that people call [ __ ] i thought like
okay people might crap on this but i
know me i'm probably gonna like this and
i was like no i just as a
as a matrix film i was disappointed as
just a film film i was disappointed
ultimately i was just kind of like
disappointed and i just progressively
got more bored as it went that really
pains me right now as it stands on my
first viewing i am pretty surprised by
how much i was not digging this at all
and it really bums me out
like a lot if anything that's the
feeling i have i'm i'm bummed
and uh i hope on a re-watch i like it
more and i'll let you guys know if i do
but if you're interested at all give it
a shot for yourself i i guess i would
say
yeah man i mean if most people walk out
feeling more like john along those lines
uh then cool i i i wish i really wish i
felt that way well guys like subscribe
and leave your thoughts below if you saw
the matrix resurrections whose team are
you on divide us in the comments pit us
against each other john you're the
biggest rob zombie fan i know
yeah
yeah this is me and a couple of people
you want to hear about what i like about
halloween
resurrection i would love to see rob
zombie's matrix are you kidding me
people yelling at me
about what's wrong with warner brothers
you can yell at me all you want it's
just how i feel
and uh
yeah